parmi padam padam padam
salut françois bonjour casimir bonjour
bonjour monsieur du sna ma promo casimir
regarder les bons fruits que j'ai dans
mon pagnol il ya des primes des pêches
des pêches abricots des pommes des
poires des raisins vous en vouliez un
oui très tangible voilà
doublant ou non ça va on est remarquable
digne des plus grandes tables et blanc
avec plaisir puisque dix meurtres
opposent je vais prendre un grain de
raisin
ou as tu trouvé tout ça et bien j'ai dit
monsieur beauchesne à faire la
cueillette il m'a donné pour ce panier
limoges ignorer qu'il y avait des fruits
aussi savoureux dans l'île jusqu'à
présent non il m'a dit qu'un autre fois
ces arbres donné par de très bons fruits
ou alors ils les abris faits il les a
quoi orange a fait ce que l'on fait dans
ce cas là il les a griffé grid tu sais
ce que ça veut dire mais bien sûr
bien sûr que non mais d'abord gazinière
on ne dit pas griffé on dit greffer à
faire une greffe les enfants vous pouvez
expliquer à casimir ce que c'est que de
faire une greffe
comment une broche est encore très fort
avec un oui c'est bien ça à rien casimir
je te faire un dessin je prendrai à
comprendre pourquoi ton et moi le
tableau messieurs le snob
prenons un arbre par exemple un arbre
fruitier
qui n'est pas très très très très bonne
santé et dont on va améliorer la qualité
des fruits on le coupe net
comme ceux ci et ont fait une fente
avec un instrument tranchant qui
s'appelle un greffoir
voilà d'autre part on prend une branche
là notre arbre en pleine santé
ont fait une entaille
en bas
on appelle ceci le greffon et on va
introduire le greffon à l'insérer dans
la fente de l'arbre à soignies et de
voir
ensuite on va prendre un lien et on va
serrer très très très très fort autour
comme sa cousine ya deux ans
cette nouvelle branche le greffon là se
nourrir de la sève
du sujet à traiter voilà qui a compris
cabinet ans j'ai compris
c'est qu'il ya d'autres d'autres greffe
pardo ya par exemple si c'est la greffe
en écusson
doit on fait une fente enter dans les
corses on soulève les corses et sous
celles ci on met le bourgeon et ensuite
on sait avec des liens toujours la même
technique encore un fils aussi regardent
celle ci c'est une greffe en
couronne en quoi ça ressemble à une
couronne en effet voilà casimir merci et
bien voilà le résultat le voici capot
alex hervaud les enfants s'est dévoué
pour lui
au tout à lui a bien tort de te plaindre
tu sais toi de la chance d'être une
tortue moi je t'envie bon bah tu trouves
je préfère à avoir deux bras et deux
jambes comme toi si tu ne te rends pas
compte de la chance que tu en as bon tu
peux courir jouer à saute-mouton
gambader faire des cabrioles avec ton
ami léo nos abris tandis que moi quand
je porte ma maison sur mon dos je suis
lente jeunes traînent ça me fatigue oui
mais tu peux voyager
même si tu marches lentement tu peux
aller très loin et l'un porte ou sans
souffrir de l'inconfort lorsque tu veux
dormir tu t'arrêtes là où tu te trouves
qui rentre dans sa carapace m'étais bien
à l'abri c'est économie non mais vous
semblez pas content de votre sort enfin
il ne faut pas être envieux je suis sûr
que si vous aviez la possibilité
d'échanger vos conditions vous
recommanderiez aussitôt à redevenir
comme avant au nom alors je serai aussi
content d'être une partie et moi grand
chien vert comme touba vous emmène à
bastien certains vous savez il ne faut
jamais être trop certains de ces choses
là enfin vous l'aurez voulu puisque vous
voulez changer
bracali mutsch babouche
qu'est ce qui m'arrive musique c'est en
gros si tu encore raté ton tour tu n'es
pas bon magicien mousse corps et voix la
moitié transformé je ne suis pas devenu
une tortue et je ne ressemble à rien moi
la seule à être désagréable débarrasse
mois de ça il m'a dit m'a embauché un
mauvais mois de mai regards ont eu de
quoi j'ai juridique elle fait quelque
chose coaching ainsi patience mes amis
ne pas paniquer ne vous inquiétez pas
c'est sérieux un peu une erreur peut
arriver à tout le monde bon je viens
ronger san attention ne bougeait pas un
peu près attention 1,2 à brac à limoux
ce bagousse
rémois
changer alors pas bien
oulaï a vraiment falloir que je passerai
paraissait de baguette magique va plus
du tout a luz allez ouste badaboum pas à
l'oustaou à la bouche
[Musique]
l'amour
a luz bat ou
[Musique]
non mais enfin casimir m'expliquera tue
tout ce remue-ménage plus tard léonard
plus tard transport va revenir d'un
instant à l'autre avec d'autres paquets
et je dois un ranger ceci s'il veut
pouvoir poser les autres
je vais mettre le grand derrière la
malle
attention
attention tu me fait tomber le couvercle
sur le crains excuse moi
décidément la vie devient possible pour
moi dans cette maison on écoute d'une
part il y a dans ses parcs et
d'excellentes choses à manger des bonnes
choses à manger et donc on parle je vais
avoir besoin de ton aide mais attend un
instant françois des pistes war apporte
vite les derniers colis
casimir est ce qu'on mangera d'abord où
est ce que je t'aiderai d'abord s'il en
sciences et expliquerait rang prendre je
t'ai fait delà de la place là j'arrive
voilà dix mois
paula casillas ce sont les derniers
d'une caméra la prochaine fois que tu me
demandais tout petit coup de main c'est
un petit peu plus clair m'enfin c'est
pas croyable tu renouvelles ton mobilier
ou quoi non non léonard et moi nous
faisons simplement tels que provisions
pour l'hiver mais sans léonard oui bien
sûr que quelques provisions pour l'hiver
tout ça pour l'hiver on sait que l'hiver
pour le printemps
ne comprends c'est une bonne chose
d'être prévoyants drame invités 1
qu'est-ce qui aborde des bananes farci
au pilori au piment vert
des saucisses au caramel on a là des
cornichons frotter dans la vanille
du boudin blanc aux groseilles moulu
dao au potiron tu veux après tout ce ne
sera pas la peine de m'inviter bon je
m'ennuie pas avec vous mais je suis
fatigué il faut que j'aille me reposer
chez j'ai les jambes coupées alors que
je retourne à mes ballons au revoir en
français et merci à vous casimir et moi
au courant donc voilà d'abord nous
allons descendre tous ces paquets dans
le tunnel qui correspond avec le kiosque
giuly est alors ensuite
j'ai on est sûr et certain les clauses
it
up
attrape
il pince une voiture
qui n'attire dedans
il ya un panier
et qui n'a t-il dans tagne
il ya de la paille
qui n'a t-il dans lapin
[Rires]
il a une bouille
qui est il sous la poule
et qui n'a t-il dans la
il ya le blanc est qu'ils n'indiquent en
blanc
il y là le jaune
qui n'a t-il dans le jaune
julien une aiguille
qu'y at-il dans l'éguille
lui à un trou
et qu'y at-il dans true
une grosse bête qu'ils courent après toi
voilà casimir c'est le dernier ce n'est
pas trop tôt je n'en peux plus je vais
défaire la ficelle ça n'avancera pas
merci c'est gentil très parlant c'est
surtout pour en mettre un peu de côté tu
m'as promis un bon repas n'est ce pas
alors prends ce que tu veux encore de
ceux ci c'est un art en effet terminé
[Rires]
quasi mais que ses tubes gravés sur ce
dos
alors chers amis vous avez vu l'arbre
enfin que s'est il passé mon père kassim
était devenu complètement fou enfin je
ne vois vraiment pas ce qui vous étonne
je fais comme mathieu beauchesne comme
monsieur beauchesne dégâts f1 je suis en
train de greffer des arbres à
gloubiboulga
[Musique]